Republicans and Democrats clashing on
Capitol Hill in a fiery first hearing
for since Republicans took the house
over the Border crisis GOP Texas
Congressman Wesley hunt was at was at
the whole thing saw the fireworks
Congressman I love one of your comments
was you've been a uh Africa you've been
black most of your life uh so because
you were pretty amazed that they were
bringing up racism as a reason that your
the Republicans are concerned about the
Border
absolutely could not believe that
because this is absolutely nothing to do
with race and and we were talking about
Fentanyl and it's my opinion that
fentanyl doesn't care about race either
when you look at what's happening at our
border you're looking at what's
happening with human trafficking right
here in Houston Texas where I'm the
congressman for congressional district
38. you look at what's going on right
here in our community and this has
absolutely nothing to do with race and
when you become the boy that cried wolf
like the left has become and everything
is about race that it actually weakens
those times when race is an actual issue
so what my goal is going to be on this
committee is to make sure that we don't
allow them to use race as a scapegoat
for everything and let's get down to
brass tacks as to what's important to
the American people and how can we fix
some of these issues that's happening at
the border that's killing people every
single day of course and when you say
things that are killing people you're
talking about fentanyl uh to the to the
Democrats they made it very clear
yesterday that most of the seizures of
fentanyl in coming across our Southern
border are at the ports of entry and
it's uh it's stuff in cars being driven
by Americans and relatively they said
for the most part it's pretty much zero
for the people who are uh trying to
travel and come into the country between
the ports uh do you buy that
absolutely not the cartels have full
control over our Sovereign border right
now there are funneling Fentanyl and
there are killing Americans at a rate we
have not seen in the history of this
country enough fentanyl has poured into
our country to kill every single
American five times we know better than
that but they're also working at Cahoots
with China That's providing the fentanyl
to the cartels that are now killing our
young people that's the bottom line and
they can try to tell us whatever they
want in filibuster and say that you know
it's not about that and that we're
racist and that we're xenophobic but
quite frankly we have the truth on our
side as long as we are willing to tell
it and I think we're going to do just
that over the course of the next few
months on this issue yeah I mean after
listening to Adam Schiff and to Nadler
some of the Democrats that were there
you're just like what in the world they
pull the race card and then they say
that Biden has continued Trump's
policies meanwhile they've ended remain
in Mexico they're not allowing to build
a wall they're not allowing even those
big what are those big containers On the
Border in Arizona the shipping
containers but they're but they're
saying another thing they're saying he's
continued Trump's policies so why when
they look at the numbers and they know
that 98 people on the terrorist watch
list came in in fiscal year 2022 how do
they justify allowing so many people to
come in our country without vetting them
it's completely Un-American when 911 hit
I was a sophomore at West Point and my
class is one of the first classes to
actually go to Afghanistan and Iraq to
Fight Against Terror and what we did was
we took a vow to Say Never Again on our
watch and now we have a president that's
allowing people on the terrorist watch
us and by the way the other terrorists
watched us for a reason and we are
allowing them to enter our country
indiscriminately and that puts us all at
risk it's very frustrating to me because
I'm somebody like many of my classmates
from West Point that decided to go serve
our country to rid the country and rid
this threat to our country from
terrorists abroad and now we are a lot
we are allowing them to simply walk
across the border the answer the answer
is no and I think Jim Jordan and our
committee has a plan on getting this
back on track to keeping our country and
the American people safe again just so
few people like Henry Clay are Democrat
who understands the problem I just give
me more Democrats can't see a place
where they could come and join you in
this because it's so important uh
Congressman Wesley times in really
quickly I'll tell you I was talking to
someone from Mexico and they said you
know we thank America for this because a
lot of these guys are drug dealers a lot
of them are taking Fentanyl and they're
leaving our country to come to America
so we're glad you're cleaning up Mexico
I thought haven't thought about that
perspective
oh my goodness oh of course ma'am look
this is this is a great place to be this
is the rarest country in the world if
there's a reason why people are risking
their lives to get here all right
Congressman thank you very much for
joining us on this Thursday
thank you so much God bless you have a
great day all right I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis